closer to the shores of Norway than
Westminster the orkney islands are far
removed from the decisions that govern
them but for the people who make a
living from these waters who governs
them camps show fish one of the islands
biggest exports and these lobsters will
be shipped south ending up on the plates
of London's restaurants I travel to
Kirkwall to meet the men who catch them
one side making their case obvious from
the start but less clear is whether they
and the politicians can reach any
agreement give us the positive case for
a defendant's positive kids wouldn't
depends whether everything is closer to
the people and we're a country of 5
million and like Denmark and Norway and
these countries will just be better run
you're just closer to the seats of power
I think that there's huge opportunity
for people in Scotland to have a great
deal i see and the future of our islands
and Scotland and the things that are
close to the people who live here work
here what are the downside risks for you
if the yes side prevail well it's
something like I understand I mean
everybody all of us here want the same
thing we all want to be a walk away and
make things better for war shells and
what families well won't have a nice
house a car holiday new and again
knighthood occasionally and ninety
percent of the politicians in Hollywood
don't want is to have that one of the
main arguments from the No campaign is
that a united kingdom is better to do
things like police britain's waters
stand up for britain on the
international stage tell us how you
think a yes vote will benefit the
fishing industry marine scotland would
make a far better job of running
fisheries then if you're Robert
definitely I'm over an issues from
marine Scotland in
we all the wishes from marine Scotland
but there would be our issues with
Nadine Scotland not a rather remote
london-based thing the fishing industry
would well it's only to be half a
percent a scottish gdp whereas I think
the strawberry picking industries higher
than the UK towns so it would have a far
better voice and be listened to a little
bit more than it is a present how do you
square that with a fact that most a
Scottish politicians are completely and
efficient and they're the bump that were
got through the post you know for the
Scottish Government yes campaign get
detail and all that beautiful rosy plans
for a future where everybody's going to
get everything for free they didn't
mention the fashion industry they're a
voice on your behalf yeah it's a
Democratic Society will have ended up
their voice on your behalf you have to
go to them and explain to them that this
is what you would like to put forward
there isn't actually we don't actually
live in a democratic country I don't
think politicians are aunty fishing I
think that pretty I would ignorance not
very good but they did all our knowledge
about the fishing and the sphere of the
last UK fisheries minister couldn't tell
you them Trina haddock enough waiting or
a haddock and anything actually so it's
more like a knowledge of the fishing and
the scene i do believe an independent
Scotland one of the things they should
have is a dedicated fisheries minister
that deals with fisheries a moment we're
just playing a game but it's were handed
the money and given the rules to play
words whereas we'll make up our own
rules and get our own money if there is
a mess it's our own mess not somebody
else's mess that we can blame somebody
on the best well then blame somebody on
it that's the same thing could happen
the [ __ ] because people self-belief I
think if you're running your own affairs
it's just so much better for you and
your own feelings and goodness one what
do you think would be if said we
actually got what Scotland wanted and we
had a the labour party in power for the
last 40 years buddy Hank would be IMA
that's what repeat
we're not much better off than Greece at
the moment and I one can even borrow
money cheaper than us at the moments I
don't really know where we're going
without one robber listen if we were in
the car and market not on at least would
get to the meetings the Scottish
specialist managed us to sit in a car
that outside at the moment at least
he'll be end he'll be in the meeting
rather than sitting in a corridor
waiting for whoever the UK fisheries
minister this at the moment you're the
guy that all all the politicians want to
talk to right now because you're
undecided what are the sort of issues
that are going to help you make up your
mind well we haven't been given enough
information to decide this is far too
much unknown to make a big decision like
what were being asked to do and and well
we'll just see this I yes and it all
goes wrong where do we go from there
thus you know we're very uninformed we
don't have any information what they're
going to do or tax what we're going to
do with our health service you know how
do you decide this is a decision that
once you've made it you've made it
forever there's not there's no going
back on this does that in any way
unnerve you could you name me one
country that has left the British Empire
or you go to aisle and have you stood in
a platform let's go reunify with the UK
I don't think you get very many votes
Canada Arden there's nobody rushing to
come back we will talk about scotch
whisky food and drink fish has been
great exports but of course one of
Scotland's biggest exports is people I'm
in Scotland is is depopulating do you
think that if Scotland votes yes people
are going to come back that's a lot of
angel here for people to stay i would
say canis this huge potentially economic
value are in these islands and houghton
an RC machine oil reserves gas reserves
it's called a dog [ __ ] yes there's there
some people in the Shetlands who want
their independence would only ever want
independence remove from an independent
Scotland well that's already in the
pipeline this hour like our Islands our
future you know splitting off for
Scotland or have an extra power only if
you vote yes only if you vote yes and I
mean I couldn't think of a more
nightmarish scenario and having the guys
in school police in charge or me I mean
good heavens if it all goes wrong where
do we go we're okay at the minute I'm
not saying it's great but we're okay and
you know if we vote yes and it all goes
bad where do we stand then I don't think
you should have any worry abou and I'll
go and completely bare ship then yes if
you I mean the whole thing is that we
all vote and we all make assertions you
have the mic decisions every day our
life and I mean if you're close up there
people who are putting forward alleges
that they just left side of things when
it comes the up the session then then I
think you'll be as real placed through
Holyrood than Westminster yes close up
everything everything that you do on the
see whether it's entitlements for
culture and fresh whatever a desk I mean
definitely better place through all in
this is a decision forever you know this
is this is your kids your grandkids how
are you going to face them well it
actually really worried me if I had to
explain to my grandchildren how come
Boris Johnston and Nigel Farage were
Prime Minister advice at prime minister
that would really worried me more than
al examen de nicolas tugjob given any
lived there even that nice tory lady
that used to be there should be even
better than any of them so it's at least
she was what you got in the packet i
would be more embarrassed about forests
and nigel so that would be my answer to
what I'd say to my grandchildren I would
I vote yes